the jurgen experience well let me ask
you this like being a libertarian and
reducing government is what you're
really interested in so if that's the
case what are the things that get
drastically reduced like like besides
the obvious ones like military and
let's what is what are the things that
you feel there's egregious misspending
or overspending on well i mean okay so
right i mean i i know you've said
besides that but i'm still gonna just
react number one is is ending all of the
wars i mean it's just been it's it's
been does one disaster after another
millions of innocent people have been
killed as a result of the wars in the
last 20 years we have nothing to show
for them nothing as we should end every
last one of them and the biggest one the
biggest one right now is what's going on
in yemen and there's talks that they're
talking about yemen again yes but you
were on ce cup five years ago it's still
and literally there and no one listened
to me then
and
um fortunately no one has yet and now
they're talking about escalating it but
it's the worst thing in the world what
is the biggest explain what's going on
so uh all right so basically obama
started a war in yemen or i mean it's
it was obama's
government working with the saudis to to
launch a war against the houthis in
yemen and basically the back story to it
is that obama had really the saudis were
pissed off at our government and they're
a big trading partner in ours but number
one they were against the war in iraq uh
that george w bush started because they
kind of were the only ones who saw
obviously how this was gonna go and they
were like you know their big enemy is
iran
and you were like well if you overthrow
the sunni minority government in iraq
obviously the shiites are going to take
power and then iran's going to have all
of this influence in the region so
you're just empowering our worst enemy
so don't do this but america wanted to
do it israel wanted to do it all of the
neocons wanted to do it and so the war
ended up happening um and so the war
happens it went exactly that way it was
the it was a gift to iran um and then
obama came in and he
uh you know made the deal with iran that
also really pissed off the saudis so
obama said and you can google this and
you can find it he said in order to
placate the saudis
he supported their war
against the houthis in yemen so we got
involved in a war
which has turned into a genocide to
placate one of the most evil governments
in the world the saudis so obama that's
that's what obama the the man who won
the nobel peace prize
gave us and said that besides um you
know for funding bin laden islamists in
libya and syria and committing literal
treason he should be tried for war
crimes and literally spend the rest of
his life in a cage for what he did in
yemen literally launched a war of gem
genocide to placate the saudis is that
really the only motivation for us
getting involved
it's i mean yeah they're basically that
they're a big business partner of ours
and we were pissed off and we were
worried about losing that uh
relationship in this war
the united states is
part is what so basically well okay so
it's really it's the saudis and the uae
um are really launching the war but it's
always i mean it's the saudis doing it
but with american weapons for the first
uh like several years of the war we were
literally refueling their fighter pilots
as they were doing it and they're
they're conducting the war in the most
brutal egregious way i mean they're
bombing like they're bombing farms and
they're bombing you know and they put a
full blockade around the country um so
there's there there was something at one
point there was in the ballpark of a
million cases of cholera i'm not sure if
they were actually all cholera or there
were some other
similar like uh infections that were but
it's been
hundreds of thousands of people who have
died in in this war the un said it was
the number one humanitarian crisis in
the world and it's it's these are uh you
know
um infectious diseases that are that are
targeting or that that
disproportionately hit babies i mean
there's babies dying um and yemen by the
way before all of this was the poorest
country in the middle east and they
would put a full blockade around the
country and this has been going on
forever obama started it trump continued
it through his entire presidency funded
uh um you know funded the saudis even
more than obama had gave them even more
uh um you know weapons um
and biden said he was going to end it
and he said he was going to end the war
and there were some people i will say
bernie sanders and rand paul were both
really great on this in the senate
trying to bring awareness to this that
we got to end this this like this is a
genocide at this point um and
biden said he was going to end it and he
didn't he backed off of that promise and
now i guess the houthis launched a few
attacks that hit uh the the united uh uh
the the uae
and so
now they're they're talking about
escalating the war
anyway so that's the biggest so it's
what government should stop doing that's
like the biggest one to me is like cut
the military budget drastically stop
stop fighting stupid wars um
anyway on top of that i would say that
the um we need to end
uh all corporate
welfare can we stop before you move on
to that sure so what the the motivations
that they have for getting involved in
wars that benefit saudi arabia are
is it
negotiations in terms of like oil access
is it negotiations in terms of like
control the region
was it like
there's compromises in terms of like
they make these compromises in terms of
like we want to do this and you want to
do that so we'll allow you to do this we
do that and then we'll work together so
there's i
i there's several really big like um
financial incentives uh behind it um the
number one uh saudi arabia buys a
tremendous amount of weapons
um so there this is worth a lot of money
for for weapons manufacturers uh there's
also the whole petro dollar thing where
there it has been this agreement for a
long time that saudi arabia will peg
their their oil to u.s dollars and only
trade in dollars and this does a lot to
keep our currency afloat that was the
reason that was part of the reason why
the the war with iraq happened right
wasn't that didn't that have something
to do with them taking their money
like taking the they weren't going to
put their oil on the u.s dollar anymore
supposedly saddam hussein around the
year 2000 um had a plan to start trading
oil you know in gold and other assets
and not using dollars anymore um i've
also seen people say that qadhafi had
had plans to to be in on this i don't
know if that's if that's true or not i
do think it's interesting i do know that
very shortly after we got off the gold
standard after richard nixon put us on
the gold stand took us off the gold
standard that we made this deal with
saudi arabia in the 70s where they would
only trade oil for dollars which in some
ways kind of replaced
the the gold standard like look dollars
aren't redeemable for gold anymore but
they are redeemable for oil and so you
got some commodity kind of behind the
money and that allows us to print as
much money as we want to
without suffering the consequences of it
quite as drastically because there's
still some value to the money for other
people we can export our dollar around
the world
i i'm sure there's other motivations
that i don't know about you know
that i don't know for sure what they are
but i do know that hundreds of thousands
of innocent people are being slaughtered
over these wars so whatever exactly the
motivation is it ain't worth it and it's
also one more crazy uh you know addition
to all of this is that we're fighting on
the side of al qaeda
over there like al qaeda is fighting the
houthis there's still a pretty sizable
al-qaeda presence in the arabian
peninsula and particularly in yemen and
they're the enemies of the houthis we're
fighting on the side of saudi arabia and
al qaeda against the houthis because
they're on the because iran kind of
likes them
it's nuts
and we need to just stop doing it and
it's insane while our country's falling
apart we're still trying to like remake
the world
it's just it's the idea that the reason
why they're making these concessions to
these other foreign countries is that
ultimately does help america
in some sort of a way well i mean i'm
sure they would talk about like a cia
guy or someone who's like involved in
this sort of uh
international politics yes kind of
explain not saying that you would agree
with them but explain to you the the
motivation or why it's beneficial to be
involved with these companies countries
rather well yeah i mean i've heard uh i
have talked to several of them and i've
heard a lot of their arguments by the
way there's also a lot of those guys who
would agree with me on this or i would
agree with them i should probably say
more accurately i mean i'd highly
recommend anybody who who wants to know
what's really going on to listen to
colonel douglas mcgregor who is as smart
and as decorated as as you could
possibly be and he's the guy who really
makes the argument the best that we
should be completely out of all of these
wars is he retired uh yeah
i believe he is at this point yeah i
believe he is but he was actually um i
believe he was mcmaster's
boss at one point but mcmasters you know
rose up i guess the political stuff with
it did a little bit better than him and
he ultimately became you know the guy
and he didn't but also might be because
of what they their views are on this
stuff but yeah there are people who will
make these arguments but really usually
the arguments that you know they come
down to like well
i mean it's like the way the wars were
sold it's like well we had to go into
iraq because of whatever weapons of mass
destruction or we had to go into syria
because assad was killing all of his own
people or we had to go into libya
because he was about to go genocidal or
we had to go into blah blah yemen they
don't really try to make this argument
as much for
just kind of like it's never disgusting
it's just there's just no there's no
real strong defense it's been going on
so how many years now it's like we're
you were talking about eight years
seven years maybe now
um yeah and it's been and it's just and
now they're talking about ramping it up
after biden promise to to end it
you